el atacante apuntó contra este centro de
Cuidado infantil primero disparó contra
el personal que estaba almorzando en las
afueras y derribó una puerta para entrar
atacó a los niños con un cuchillo y una
pistola la mayoría de sus víctimas
tenían entre dos y tres años de edad al
huir de la escena atropelló a una mujer
y volvió a su casa para matar a su
esposa e hijo antes de suicidarse
panyang de 34 años era un ex oficial de
policía que fue suspendido en enero y
despedido en junio por consumo de drogas
anteriormente sirvió en la estación de
policía en nahuán provincia de
nongualampú al tener un comportamiento
relacionado con drogas y ser detenido
con mentafetamina se le ordenó retirarse
del servicio poco antes del ataque había
comparecido ante un tribunal por cargos
de posesión de estupefacientes El Primer
Ministro de Tailandia expresó sus
condolencias y solicitó una
investigación por lo ocurrido
he recibido el informe estamos revisando
los motivos sabemos que era un policía
que podría tener problemas personales la
sociedad debe cuidar de todos puede que
tuviese problemas internos no me pongo
de lado de nadie definitivamente esto no
debería suceder siento una profunda
tristeza hacia las víctimas y sus
familiares nadie pensó que esto
sucedería la posesión de armas en
Tailandia es alta en comparación con
otros países en el sudeste asiático sin
embargo los tiroteos masivos son raros
uno de los peores ocurrió en 2020 cuando
un soldado disparó a 29 personas e hirió
a decenas antes de morir a manos de un
grupo Comando